well so then Geppetto shows up and he's
a kindly old guy which is pretty much
exactly what you'd expect and you know
he he's a careful craftsman and he likes
kittens and you know that's always a
good thing
and he has some fish and you know he's
and he's good at making things and he's
got a sense of humor and he's kind of
playful and so he's the good father
fundamentally he's the wise King he's
the positive archetype of the masculine
that's what he is
and so he's culture in its positive
manifestation and he gives rise to this
creation which is his puppet which is
what culture does because you're a
puppet of your culture you're a
marionette of your culture and so maybe
you could be more than that and that's
the other thing that's strange about
this movie and it's strange about the
mythological way of looking at the world
because scientifically deterministically
there's nature and there's culture and
you are the deterministic product of the
interaction between nature and culture
there's nothing else to you than that
that's that but the mythological world
doesn't say that it says something
different it says that there's nature
and culture and then there's you and the
you that's in there has choices and a
destiny and that you actually affect the
interplay of nature and culture in
determining your own character and it
insists upon that the oldest stories we
have there's always the hero and the
archetypal mother and the archetypal
father there's always those three things
there's never just two so from the
narrative perspective there's always the
implication that there's something
autonomous about the the hero of the
story and you know you can't account for
that we don't have a good way of
accounting that for that from a
scientific perspective I was having a
discussion with Sam Harris the other day
which was very what would you say
he said we got wrapped around an axle
which is pretty much FM Harris is one of
the four famous you know atheists along
with Christopher Hitchens and Richard
Dawkins and Dan Dennett yeah and so we
were having a discussion and he's a
determinist just right down to the
bottom it's like you're dieter
and you're determined there's no free
will you're a deterministic machine and
you know if you're a coherent scientist
and you're a Newtonian roughly speaking
you don't really have much choice other
than to think that way but that isn't
how it seems to people and we don't
treat each other that way and our entire
legal system is predicated on the idea
that you do in fact have free will so
well can we account for it
well no and do we have a scientific
model for it no but then I would also
say we do not have a scientific model
for consciousness we don't know a damn
thing about consciousness which is why
Dan Bennett's book which was called
consciousness explained was referred to
its critics as consciousness explained
away which is exactly right as far as
I'm concerned because he took a
mechanistic approach and I just don't
think you get to do that because there's
something really weird about
consciousness I mean the phenomenologist
like Heidegger who tried to radically
transform Western philosophy right from
the bottom-up he basically said well you
know you can treat the world as if
consciousness is primary and that human
experience is reality that's reality and
that it doesn't exist independently of
consciousness in any explicable way it's
like well what's out there if there's
nothing to experience it
well everything at once it's something
like that it's not really comprehensible
as without a subject the subject defines
it and makes it real now you don't have
to believe that but but at least I'm
telling you that there are thoroughly
coherent philosophical positions that
make that case very strongly and that
that allow consciousness to exist as a
phenomenon and to take it seriously and
you certainly act like you take it
seriously you act like there's a you and
that you make choices and you certainly
treat other people that way
deterministic or not you're still going
to get angry when they're being you know
rude to you and you're going to act as
if they had some choice in the matter
now maybe that's an illusion possibly
but maybe it's not and I would say the
oldest stories that we have always
include that as not only our fundamental
element but even as the fundamental
element